بعض النقرات بواسطه الكمبيوتر فازت بجائزه
مميزه في مجال التصوير الفوتوغرافي من
جديد يتصاعد التنافس ومعه مخاوف المصورين
والفنانين من تهديد برامج الذكاء
الاصطناعي لمصدر رزقهم
الجدل هذه المره حول جوائز سوني العالميه
للتصوير الفوتوغرافي فالفائز الالماني
بولس الدكسن رفض ان يتسلم جائزه مرموقه
لانه استخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي في رسمها
سوره الفنان الفائزه تظهر فيها امراتان
وتحمل عنوان سودومينجيا هي من فئه الاعمال
الابداعيه لكنه قال انه كان واضحا منذ
البدايه فيما يخص طبيعه عمله وانه لا
يستحق الجائزه لان مسابقات مماثله ليست
جاهزه بعد للتعامل مع تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي
اما اللجنه المسؤوله عن منح الجوائز
بدورها قالت انها كانت على علم بطبيعه
الصوره لكنها اتهمت الفنان بتضليل متعمد
وهو ما اثار غضب الديكسن